we have this story from the daily mail
addicted to being sad teenage girls with
invisible illnesses known as spoonies
post tic tocs of themselves crying or in
hospital to generate thousands of likes
as experts raise concerns over internet
induced wave of mass anxiety this is
real it's true that young women are
getting depressed because of instagram
and tick-tock and as far as it goes with
aoc we were just talking about how she
said she might not be alive in september
which to me is indication an indication
of depression or severe i don't know
what would you call it like paranoia
but i also think it's possible that you
know she's in the limelight
in this position
if she starts putting out posts like any
other individual susceptible to
depression from these platforms and
she's not getting the likes or the
attention she might get depressed and
we're seeing this now with teenage girls
across the board well and she is one of
the most followed like has the biggest
social media presence of any member of
congress i mean she has really
cultivated her brand as being someone
who is in touch with her followers she
does upgrades updates through her
instagram live and through twitter and
things like that like as well as shares
her skincare routine and she sells fun
merch like she is as much an influencer
as she is a politician and public figure
in so many ways she's more an influencer
yeah right exactly and so in some ways
you know i could see if she's won
reelection and she's had this moment
where she was sort of this fun golden
girl for the left uh and if any of those
numbers drop like if she's getting
80 000 likes on a photo instead of the
110 000 she's gonna feel that burn so
intensely the same way that you know
teenage girls are susceptible to it too
but like it is not just her identity
it's also her career you see this
throughout the history of youtube
one day a popular youtuber will make a
video saying like i can't do this
anymore and then all you got to do is
look at the views for their past videos
and you see them going down and then all
of a sudden they snap yep so people it's
it's really amazing to me i remember
getting a message from someone it
happens all the time and they're like
are your views down and then i'll be
like yes and they'll be like dude
something's going on i'm like it's
called summer yeah summer happened
people went outside calm down yeah you
see i see these trends all the time and
there are people who you know
promote global warming so they stay
inside well i remember uh
you know like two years ago it rained
for a week straight on the east coast
across the board
and then one day
i got message of people being like dude
my views are cut in half i'm panicking
like what's going on i'm like bro the
rain stopped
everybody went outside for the first
time in a week calm down man but this is
what happens to these young girls on on
social media they'll post a picture of
themselves get 100 likes and go oh 100.
the next day they get 80
they get depressed they panic why are
they getting likes they delete the photo
and repost one can i do better can i do
better not realizing bro it's like two
in the morning people are asleep calm
down i knew girls who would when they
traveled out of the country they would
time their instagram posts to go up
they'd like set alarm for like 3 am so
it was the correct time to post in
america to get the maximum likes like i
didn't even grow up with tick tock like
this is crazy right and i think social
media is really morphed too where not
only are we seeking validation through
the likes but your depression and
anxiety is affirmed through social media
like social media used to be a highlight
reel for people's lives you follow these
influencers but you know it's not real
like they're in hawaii but they're
probably arguing with their boyfriends
behind the scenes whatever the case may
be now it's a trend to cry on social
media it's a trend to show your panic
attacks and that gets you millions of
likes or having like anxiety coping like
here are my anxiety cops or here's my
ocd cops or who are these things that i
think i'm doing that are actually very
strange behaviors or misspelling words
yeah so um
it's true that if you misspell a word in
your title you'll get more engagement as
people want to correct you wow so what
happened is a bunch of youtubers started
intentionally misspelling words like
simple typos
and then little kids who are watching it
started misspelling the words that way
thinking it was spelled correctly
yeah your social media is is melting the
brains of humanity yes and particularly
young girls i did an episode one time
because i was scrolling on on tik tok i
do have the app regrettably but i was
scrolling part of your job it is part of
my job but i kept getting videos of
young girls who have tourette's like
ticks and i kept getting them and it's
multiple girls multiple girls and i was
getting recommended these videos and
upon watching them found that several of
them had the exact same tick so i
started looking into this and doctors
talking about it and they actually had
doctors saying these girls are being so
heavily influenced by a mix of anxiety
and tick tock they are they are
developing functional neurological
disorders that are real
that are real they're not just puppeting
and parroting they're actually
developing these anxiety-induced tissues
i'm a huge fan of video games but man we
are tweaking our brains with modern
technology yes
it's like a big experiment dude the
emotional development that teenager is
going through like part of being a
teenager is looking at your peers around
you and figuring out what the social
norms are so if you're only being fed
people who are behaving in you know
maybe they really do have tourette's and
they have you know an issue and they're
trying to talk about it or bring
awareness but if you're constantly being
served like i have anxiety i have
depression i have to rats like you are
then trained to be like maybe i do too
and you start seeing it anywhere because
that's part of the emotional growth that
teenagers are going through like yeah we
should keep them away from this stuff
it's it's not we shouldn't talk about
mental health or anything like that but
like we don't need to shove it down
their throats so constantly that they
become paranoid they themselves happen
you know one of the things is that i've
noticed is it's not so important how
many followers you have it's the quality
of the followers are they really why are
they following you is it because they're
really listening to what you're saying
or is it because they want to laugh when
you fall down i don't want those people
following me and
the problem with social media is just
the number shows on your page so they
think more is better but then you get
the subscribe direct subscribers this is
where you start to realize the quality
of the follower
or the watcher or the viewer or whatever
is much better because you might have 10
000 people paying you 10 bucks a month
that he might have 10 million people
watching paying him nothing he's way
worse off you're way better off with
less followers
more quality and um hopefully young
women we can teach them that maybe
through direct
support
and they see the internet as the beyond
end-all
there's i don't remember what study came
out but most young people like one of
four want to be social media influencers
this is a whole new area of the world
that they are completely devoted to
right and they will never have a break
from it if that's the career they choose
to pursue yeah it's an augmentation to
your career social media no one is just
gonna land on being a social media
influencer and that's it because if your
life is boring no one's gonna watch your
social media you've gotta do something
cool with your life and then the social
media will be there to show everyone you
have to sell all of your personal
information you have to as a young teen
mom start talking about your past
relationships or you know as you get
married you have to give all the details
of everything that's going on you have
to sell who you are in order to please
people which is a really morally corrupt
way of living yeah i remember when i was
younger and you know like myspace first
came out and stuff like that we were on
i think it was like live journal was
first
manga
yeah i was on compuserve
you know because my family computers
then you got aol yeah then uh with aol
yeah geocities and other sites that you
can you can make your own site then
eventually you got like live journal
then you got friendster you guys
remember friends hell yeah and then
myspace
and i remember uh facebook came out and
it was like all the cool kids that are
migrating to facebook and i would see
these posts from people that just looked
so awesome and fun and i was like how
come they're doing all this really
awesome stuff and i'm not and then you
know
it wasn't until later i realized like oh
they weren't they were faking cool
things so they could look cool
and like that was their it was marketing
and so we end up we end up seeing this
highlight reel of their life of all the
coolest things they've done but they
staged a lot of it they try to make it
look as cool as possible they try to
make their lives look like movies so
that you're jealous of them my favorite
is i know girls who have um when they go
through a breakup right they start
posting on their instagram and all their
story all the time because they can't be
the one that's at home and like sad they
have to be busy and cool and having a
great time and their mind is somewhere
else like these people don't realize
they're robbing themselves of their own
actual individual lives for the sake of
other people who are viewing from their
bedrooms yes all they're giving away is
their own time which ends up being their
lives and i do want to say before we
move on from the a all this aoc talk
she's talking about holding two
completely different
views in her mind at the same time i
think she's about to get red pill
changed my mind that's what it feels
like i hope i'm right i kind of went
through something similar where i i
already mentioned this earlier yeah
sorry oh i truly believed in the
possibility of of ever of the human race
but at the same time seeing this
insurmountable you know
mountain of impossibility that i was up
against and like how the hell can i
overcome a global monetary assistance
well what if also a lot of things that
she's been preaching are not working and
she's having to reconcile the fact that
like there are policies that she is
vocally backed that she doesn't actually
she's not sure she supports she isn't
just a person she is a brand and
identity that a lot of left so want to
cultivate in their own daughters like
she can't we talk about this with jazz
jennings sometimes like there's nowhere
to go from there like this person can
only continue down this path and that's
scary aoc can't come out and be like
well that one bipartisan bill seems kind
of good you know she can't she has to
continue down this path to get voted
back in right and like if she she's
gonna get married right but if she gets
pregnant she's like well actually i'm
going to leave politics because i want
to be a mom that's anti-feminist like oh
you know i have some questions about the
way lockdown went you know maybe that's
not so good she's anti-coveted you know
she there is no escape for her and in
some ways i have sympathy that's true
you can't say i was wrong the most
feminist thing you can do alex is
whatever you want
mm-hmm take control of your life baby
such a liberating thing
at the table yeah
that's why i said yeah have a family and
do whatever you want you can always do
politics later yeah there you go yes
well i mean if she's doing what she's
watching
yeah yeah
yeah but i think like right now
the whole trend is not to have a family
and it's like you have to actually
resist the current to have a family
which is the funniest thing you know
it's like it's been a meme forever to
have it all so the women who are like
you know i decided i don't want to have
a job in a career i want to raise
children it's like it's against the
grain but it is massively feminist to do
that to take control of your life if you
want a baby well that's why i think they
intercede i don't know i mean how many
people you know who are feeling the
pressure to decide in your early 20s
that you actually don't want kids and
make a permanent decision right to go
past that like
they are trying to head the south pass
because a lot of times you actually hear
it from women who are in their late 20s
or in their early 30s were like i
thought the career was the most
important thing but i've reached this
age and i actually would prefer to focus
on my family and if you can prevent
people from ever having that door when
they hit 30 they have to continue to
stand by that they made the right choice
to get a hysterectomy when they were 20
wicked cycle we could cycle and then if
you decide at 30 that you want a family
but you don't have the man yet and you
don't have the you know song
also yep i tweeted this
abortions increase the likelihood of
miscarriage
that's true entirely yeah i mean it's
it's it's a very basic thing i you know
i saw the story from jennifer lawrence
and she was like roe v wade and things
like that
and then i was like
look if you support this stuff like
women need to be told this that if you
get abortions so like look use condoms
or whatever try not to get pregnant but
if you get an abortion you are
increasing likely that when you're older
you're not gonna be able to have kids
and that's because there's there's
damage that's caused by it it's the same
thing with uh taking birth control for
years like those have long-term effects
on the bodies but because it's seen as
this revolutionary tool that helped many
women join the workforce and gain
control of their body like we're not
supposed to criticize it and i actually
think that sets us behind i've known a
lot of women who have struggled with you
know anxiety depression different things
like that and really had to push their
doctors to be honest about the
consequences of taking hormonal birth
control and that's scary
you can't even get accurate information
because it goes against an ideology that
we are supposed to be 100 behind yeah
we've just jumped into a culture that
says this is accepted here's the thing
you need to do now do it and then 20
years later when we have the
ramifications of it we're going to be
like and i i wish women would hear that
like you are they are willing to
sacrifice you and your personal choice
and freedom and health to maintain this
illusion that the ideolo the ideology
they pushed is worth
having around dude if you are willing to
give up your power to medical tyranists
they will take it but it's empowering
ian if you take the birth control pill
it's empowering i this is terrifying
what you just said on mala because i
think that this is exactly what's
happening with the kids now so you know
how like however many years ago it was
birth control wasn't un you know unknown
but they still encouraged people to take
it it was so easy for me to get on birth
control i had to i like half made up an
excuse because like i'm 19. oh it's time
i got to figure this out right be smart
or whatever and it was easy it was the
easiest thing in the world and i'm
terrified that they're going to do the
same thing with human hormones thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you